what's going on guys welcome back to
GameSpot I am sitting next to someone
who needs no introduction he is a
two-time World Series champion a
three-time MLB all-star the starting
right fielder for the San Francisco
Giants hundred pads everybody hey man
that's that's too much no that's not an
action but super cool of you and cannot
believe that I'm here getting to play
MLB the show 2017 it's time he can't
believe it
I can't believe it this is wild we're
here we're gonna be playing some MLB the
show 17 we're gonna get started with
some some retro mode believe it you have
new variants with retro mode yeah I have
I have a slight bit of experience say
let me they let me dabble in spring
training and a cut at one of their like
opening events and I got to tell you
this is one of my favorite things and
MLB the show has ever done yeah
st. cuz like the old school they're kind
of mimicking the old school Griffey yeah
and like they have Griffey on the cover
too because they added this retro mode
and if you're an old-school like gamer
like when I was a kid I remember playing
Griffey and are you know like just all
day long on the on the Super Nintendo
but it's just it's just that where you
can like throw the curveballs and you
can like mix it as it's going yeah that
playstyle to me is so fun and now to
have any lb to this show doing it it's
like let's get in there bring it back to
the basics
yeah alright let's do this so are you
want to explain to them the game that
we're doing have you already told them
about our big league chew
okay so we gotta know this is gonna get
game going on here so hunter and I have
decided that for every run that he
scores I'm going to put a healthy wad of
bubble gum in my mouth and for every run
I score he will be doing the same so
hopefully this is a high up Cory
let's get bubblegum isn't it's a big
league chew we are we start already I
just want to open it up so I'm ready I
mean I'm the home team
so I'm pitching first like wings bite
grape flavor this is like this is how we
stream are you guys ready for some
baseball let's let's check on the chat
Nick killin it from our man Rob hand I
gotta get a little closer so I can see
hell yeah thank you rob I appreciate
that
bro we'll see we'll see who's killing it
all right John Luke gunman is hit us I'm
ready to go Madison Bumgarner you know I
feel like you have a stronger picture in
this this line up here also a little bit
your first home run with the Phillies
was off bum is that true I don't know to
be honest with you oh my I think it's
real
oh yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't know
that's pretty funny
all right here we go blue will say that
he's dominated me in spring training
since really you know whenever I was
with the Phillies I had them kind of
good Oh like that all right let's go
gotta remember these controls here that
should have been it out what is this I
don't want to say don't panic on it gold
Glover here Oh baby
wait what Hey good yeah yeah I'm gonna
readjust to the controls of the retro
mode got it so sweet Oh Casey swinging
at strikeout also counts for wad of gum
no it no it doesn't you're kidding oh
yeah yeah it's always scoring it's okay
but if you want to get a little one it's
like it will say strikeouts a little
taste just a gum going a little taste
all right just like I remember it
whoa yeah you gotta watch your out
supposed to strike out in retro mode
where am i swinging at well that was a
six deal how'd you do that what the
buttons for that I held a and I pressed
the second base
okay I need you to buy ax you mean the
hell backs held the X I don't know I
said hey why am i swing on that I don't
know buddy oh he's there we go
get in the gap you gotta be kidding me
go
I believe that to run that's gum that's
a big one
that's not that's not a small one it's a
big one a big league chew
whoa big league chew this is a big time
okay
mm-hm alright this is uh this is getting
real real quick makes it way more fun oh
man me out together mmm
two outs kill a little two out rally
going one no huh
swollen Smith what oh yeah
oh my catcher wants to throw Buster man
I don't even know how do I look up I
didn't know how I threw that changeup
one run one run
oh nice finally I'm in play big crop
Gold Glove Crawford's a recent USA
winner
I here to have WBC champ big time
brought it back to America
big time u.s. how are your does it been
Buster and Carl show up we win that was
awesome that's him but I mean obviously
it's always oh yeah it's ruined good
swing okay we're back we're back in this
way to the ball man what are you doing
what God didn't sloppy out there Tina no
not quite
you know what we might my first baseball
game was as a kid that's what it was in
his backyard baseball dude for the
softball game yeah that game was awesome
Pablo you pick like the faces of the
people yeah I love that game Pablo
Sandoval's
he was he was the slugger in that game
that's who it was
BAM sure my mom got it for me Pablo
Sandoval great day Oh who's this cat
hitting look at that look at that it's
got my grip on there and everything whoo
dude who is this guy who is this guy
what's he doing
oh he's swinging the miss that guy
stinks come on baby ah no never heard of
this guy before
oh you are
No get away get the gap triples alley
how do you run get there that's got to
be a triple what the Jesus heart all
right step your game up that's what it's
like to see yourself in a game you get
mad at yourself when you don't get a
triple or triple salad what happens all
right Steve Crocker knock it off Riggs
aah
you told me the man I'm giving you
meatball meatball sandwich
I thought your info there it goes is
that one out all right all right one out
there's a somebody that I want man I've
never heard of on 3rd currently oh he's
going home get you some big league June
that was not planned I didn't even know
I don't know how I'm running the base is
just that was not playing small stars hi
baseball stars was it I am healthy hutch
a good call whoever said that baseball
stars and bass wars all right I was oh
ha unhitch the trailer hunt you're
that's just ray hey good to see ray
that's right he needs to run man did you
know needs to start running go 3 no way
ya know what you go back for what are
the buttons someone's gotta clear this
up so you're gonna hold X and you're
gonna go towards the base I don't know
if I believe that because that's what I
was doing swear you got good to hold it
or push it hold it
stay there stay there come back get out
of here sorry bomb it but hey guys got a
big back coward with you Silver Slugger
winner right oh man dude everything he
hits feels like a ride back gun
I was very delayed reaction on my part
oh yeah that'll get added Bob all
eyeball work the picture work the
picture
Oh baby okay how everybody's going
everywhere are you in a big league chew
baby I don't know how I did it you get
that gum Chris Jameson you're dang right
not me
oh my god I've got to eat the gum okay
bigger bites bites your upped here we go
why am i swinging at that I'll gamble
you didn't see it coming I'm doing it
gonna swing swing at garbage okay there
we go
dang why did I throw him a strike if I
was gonna take go you know yeah could we
have a little inside the Parker a chance
what is it it's gotta learn the controls
a little bit what oh my god is there
anyone home oh all right
we said it bigger clothes bigger bites
nobody out just do up an inside the
Parker gotta learn these controls I
swear hurry up
unbelievable go up the middle good
hitting trying to figure it out okay
Bumgarner is doing awesome the active
nickel pixel stuff like that
Frank Oh what am i doing trying to catch
up to you I see somebody in the chats
asking about smash are you still an avid
smash player I've been watching it there
was a really good tournament like two
days ago
looks like Rosalita improvements kind of
the pro there's someone who playing link
that got to like the finals Wow awesome
that's more government alright see ya
still playing smash burger bar in
trouble why'd you be in trouble - cuz
it's a tie game I should be as deep in
huh alright this is a really cool oh all
right no no no
Archangel that's pretty much why bar
I'll be dumb
I know be silly so I can live in a fairy
tale well guys like hundred pence on
with my blue jays and bring a
championship to try them good that's
cool of you
I'm glad that there's people out there
like duel doesn't get any better than
this answering questions oh no also get
more gum you I got out answer you
questions with
No what are you serious I didn't even
have my hands on the controller I didn't
even know I tried to steal all right
okay
two outs I'm not the wolf off slice and
play this worked out way better than we
planned
if I would just stop swinging at Roush
no usually every time this is easy why
did I give up any runs you know why yeah
look up let's you can land and the runs
god this is a lot of sugar I'd be like a
specter oh yeah Lee - spitting they're
real hey can we have some cups actually
because we're gonna have to get rid of
these eyes rise you don't even have that
much I gotta score some runs or I
decided to get bigger things whenever I
was pitching a I find my bike yeah I
found my scooter oh yeah I heard uh your
age anyway uncle doesn't there we go
so you you scooter to to work correct
come on I do I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna go for it
I'm gonna put the rest of this in there
no I got a score man come on it's drop
so I believe I believe
I mean look who's at bat you didn't
forget to eat whenever I struck you out
a couple times
oh no here let me start all right we're
gonna we're gonna move on now
so that was retro mode you die sobs no
thank you
as absolutely my favorite mode thus far
Robbie some water huh we're getting arm
down I'm gonna I could power through
[Music]
foul ball
[Music]